i got to ask you a question about trump
i can get on
and and talk i i try not to talk about
trump at all people know you supported
trump and i try to say them listen
this is not a personality con concert
contest for me i liked his policies for
america that's it
yeah he's not going to date my daughter
i don't go out to dinner with him we're
not best friends i don't go to
mar-a-lago
this is one of i liked his policies and
the story but i forget about him i don't
talk about him i say something with this
current administration immediately they
don't even see that they come back at
trump
what is it
what did this guy do to make people hate
him so much
it's very obvious it's very obvious i
mean
you and i sat there and we spoke one
time and you told me about something you
learned from your dad years ago sunny
who
we had a chance to i had a chance to
meet with the most one time we had great
lunch with them at that one italian
restaurant uh and you said one of the
things i learned from my dad
is
to be able to sit down in front of
somebody
knowing they lied to your face knowing
they betrayed you
and you still
don't act like you know and you don't
publicly humiliate them something like
that and you know i'm prefacing what you
said but something like that do you
remember this guy yeah
that was it yeah
so
well
trump didn't do that
trump went publicly and called everybody
out as fake news that means he called
everybody in a blanket
media you're a liars
and he kept doing it over and over and
over and over and over again
you're essentially questioning their
character you didn't say i disagree with
their policies he didn't say i disagree
with the approach to get the economy to
improve i disagree with what we ought to
do with health insurance no no you said
you're all full of [ __ ] you're all liars
you're all fake none of you guys care
about the american people all you care
about is your pocket your dinner and
that's who you're on that's your dna
well guess what you did you woke them up
and that woke mop is coming after you
not one of them not two of them not
three of them
they're all angry at you and no one's
ever done that before until this guy did
it it's that simple you go look at uh
kennedy that kennedy and his family did
that behind closed doors
but publicly like joseph kennedy was
like a trump john f kennedy wasn't like
a trump the father is a trump you know
he was a guy that if he would have ran
joseph kennedy was probably not capable
of running at that time because he would
have talked [ __ ] to everybody that guy
was a straight up gangster 100 you know
he was a he was a feared man but his
sons learned from dad's weaknesses and
strengths right like to like even if you
look at his daughter trump's daughter
look how he she got all the strengths
from trump's trump is like okay this is
what my dad's good at but look at the
way she answers okay you're like oh okay
i can see her there's diplomacy she has
diplomacy and the father doesn't have it
but you know if if if we had a guy like
that right now would they put and be
doing what he's doing to ukraine how
would that phone call be handled they
asked the question from biden this week
what can we do about inflation you know
what his answer was there's really not
much we can do about inflation that's
not something we want to hear from the
president
there's really not much we can do about
inflation there's really not much we can
do about inflation so i think that's the
part with trump where he went out on the
offensive and called everyone's
character out well let me add to that
because i i'm so glad you went there
michael because the whole time i'm
thinking as we're talking about all
these
policies issues substantive type stuff
all i'm thinking is the elephant in the
room is no longer there so
trump sucked so much of the oxygen out
of the room that even if you had if you
were going to attempt to have a policy
debate no matter what it was
you know healthcare guns schools
you know the economy whatever everyone
from the center to the left would be
like yeah but he's a liar yeah he's a
bad guy yeah he's not presidential and
it was such a quick response that you
couldn't even have a substitute debate
what's happening now that trump is no
longer in office and the dust has
settled
and we're supposed to have grown-ups in
the white house now and you have biden
coming out there basically saying yeah
you know the gas
you know it is what it is sorry you have
someone like janet yellen basically
saying
yeah my bad i was supposed to use i
heard i never used the word transitory
in my life never heard of it and i heard
it every other sentence out of
yellen and jerome powell transitory
transitory so
the good and the bad of the trump thing
is now that he's not here we can
actually have policy debates and that's
what's happening in this country right
now and
you know believe it or not
the right
is winning these policy debates for the
most part right maybe they've you know
on guns they may be you know
hopefully will come around on some stuff
but
everything with wokism transgender
economy gas prices inflation it's so
hard to look at the left or bite in and
be like great job guys keep it up the
the whole premise of biden and everyone
that kind of accompanied him into the
white house into the oval office was
quote unquote well now we got the
grown-ups in the white house is this
what [ __ ] growing up looks like
because it looks pretty ugly but without
trump we're able to see
really what's happening right now and
again not a huge fan of trump but at
least we're able to see
what's behind the curtain but but is
that is that okay so you just made a
very good point
uh and i rarely say that we just made a
very good point
and but but the but the part about what
the part about what you just said is the
follow like he almost needed to leave
for us to know if he was doing a good
job or a bad job bingo yes got it and
now we notice where he was doing a very
good job in
and where he wasn't
and
a lot of the stuff that the media was
saying that he was doing bad they were
full of [ __ ] because yeah because they
it wasn't
the media would never attack the
policies for the most part there were
some things that were disagreeable you
know whether the tax cuts were a good
thing or not or whether you what you
want i mean he did not have a solution
whatsoever for health care right but for
the most part when you talked about the
economy blacks whites hispanics latinos
asians this that like james carville
said 1992 bill clinton 30 years to the
day
like michael said it's the economy
stupid and everything all roads lead to
the economy and
everything about trump it was he
everything was attacking his character
because like it or not the guy did lie a
lot
okay or he told fibs or whether he
called people out he i know but adam lie
a lot
i got what they all do is what you're
saying biden
can i tell you something people say we
feel sorry for biden and i'm a christian
and i'm a former gangster honestly
this guy i can't even look at him and
i'll tell you why number one he's a
tremendous liar
he's been feeding he's been living off
of the taxpayer for 47 years this guy i
guarantee never had to make a payroll in
his life he don't know what it is to end
he's been living off that
lie through his teeth about his son
lies he's his partner he knows his son
used him to get whatever and he's
sharing it the evidence is there
and i'll tell you what gets me the most
and this is something personal i get
angry just talking about it
what's happening in our southern border
i spoke to 850 undercover dea agents
from the state of texas i spoke and i
spent two days with them
they said what they said to me in two
days made me sick they said michael
we're not even getting 10
of the illegal drugs that are coming
across opioids and fentanyl and then
they they showed me something they they
wrote on a piece of paper a block like
this patrick maybe a foot and a half
square and maybe two inches thick
and they said this block of fentanyl
coming across the border can kill the
entire population of the world seven
billion people and they said we can't do
anything about it
last year alone you know the numbers a
hundred thousand people between the ages
of 24 and 45 died of opioid overdose
including somebody very close to me okay
good beautiful kid some call he knows
this is happening they know it's it's
happening this 15 year old kids they're
finding they're finding opioids in their
rooms in in their in their lockers in
school you know this is happening and
you allow this because you bring it the
whole scheme is so easy to see you're
bringing these people in you want to get
mail-in votes then you want to send your
troops out at the election time and say
hey biden got you here if you want to
stay here you better vote this way you
don't need an id just mail the ballot in
and that's it it's all about staying in
office it's all about money and power
and control and that's what the book is
about let somebody deny that to me
let them deny it these are these are
they're murderers
i hate to say but it's true
how could you allow this look
i i don't know guys on the street that
would do this patrick i mean it we
didn't do this in our own neighborhoods
we took care of our communities even
sammy you spoke to sam we didn't mess
with our neighbor we took care of the
people in our neighborhood in our
community we had a heart for things like
that some guys okay
talk about roy demaio as different
animal you know different animal but for
the most part how could you allow this
to happen
is this that important to you nancy
pelosi
woman's 81 years old you've been in
power you're a multi-millionaire you you
you might have come into how come these
people come into offices with
blue-collar assets and go out
multi-millionaires
on a 200 000 a year's salary
i mean this is what they're doing to the
american people and yes it's on both
sides but i got it for biden because i
know this is happening and he's doing
nothing about it nor any of the
democrats that right now are in control
and this this is basically murder
they're allowing it to happen you know
so many people that i've spoken to
because you know i travel the country
so many people that i've spoken to have
lost loved ones over opioid or uh you
know what do you call it
overdose yeah i get so angry about it
yeah no i get it it drives me crazy how
could you allow this to happen but i
don't feel sorry for him at all
i don't let me tell you something if i
was running for office and my wife knew
that i was abiding she would she would
divorce me for she before she'd allow me
to be president
i mean you these people are all frauds
they're all frauds what are they trying
to do
biden's been office 47 years he's a
multi-millionaire you have to put the
country in this kind of shape go and
take care of your grandchildren live the
rest of your life enjoy yourself i don't
get it the nancy pelosi the same thing
go enjoy your life
why do you have to make people miserable
and this is coming from a former
gangster
but look i got kids and grandchildren i
got a heart i go speak in detention
centers talk to young kids
they don't real
they have to realize what they're doing
and they don't care
and this to me is more serious than
anything else adam it i i take it
personal even if it wasn't a personal
thing and i would still take it personal
because they're wreaking havoc on this
country and
if it is true and again i i can't verify
this i can't say it's a fact i know what
i've been told but if china
is sending the drugs to mexico mexico is
processing them and bringing them over
in their mules
well this is another thing that china
look you know this every great nation
that ever fell it fell from within roman
empire on down fell from within
this country now i think every young man
should go into the military
so many of them are soft they don't know
they don't even get i mean they're on
their phones they don't even know what
it is you know to to
to break their backs at all they should
go into the military you know that
you've been there and get training this
country is getting very weak our
military is getting woke
you know
i ran in venezuela now partnership china
and i and russia getting to i mean
what's going on here i mean are we going
to be around in 20 years i know you say
different patrick but i don't know this
country is is getting weak from within
they call it the wussification of
america yes a lot of the highlights well
let me do i'm doing a sermon on on uh
you know at a big church greg laurie's
church you know who he is and you know
what it is it's what it what to be um
what is it to be a man's man in 2022
guys got to man up
i'm so i'm i'm really concerned i really
am about what's going on in this country
i think we're in a lot of trouble
i think it's going to unify the right
group of people
uh you know everything's in messaging
sometimes people don't have messaging
right and uh
people are getting the messaging in a
more
way that's connecting with the audience
uh younger people are starting some of
the younger people are starting to rise
up and talk about some things that we
didn't talk about before
you got the
guys are talking about what it is to be
a man today and hey you know
something happens you rely on a man to
go fix this or do that and people are
starting to talk about this today the
last 30 years men have been wussified
you know whatever you want to call it
where
they're pansies but we're going back to
admiring what man's men are
and women see that yeah
where oh social you're even with the
what uh rollo is doing with some of
these guys people people are going to
get a bigger voice on this jordan
peterson what he's doing he's talking
about you know men you know
on the inside there's a monster it's
okay to be that because that's how we
are and we're supposed to be that way
and he's getting billions of eyeballs on
top of billy's eyeballs and people are
sitting there saying this kind of does
make sense and a lady interviews jordan
and says so look at me i'm 45 years old
i've never been married and what's wrong
with that i'm a career woman and i've
done very well and papa papa says why do
you have such a problem with that i
don't have a problem with that
but if you're 45
and you're single and your best years
are behind you as a woman to find a good
prospect
what the risk you took for just being a
courier person you're going to live a
very lonely life exactly and if you're
okay with that or power to you okay but
but this is the part this feminism
movement of living a lonely life it
takes a little bit while for people to
see what the side effects are you know
so for example steroids okay
do we know the negative and the positive
side effects of steroids well when it
first came out nobody knew right 80
years later guess what now we know what
it does to the liver we're learning
about what it does to this vaccine do we
know the side effects of the vaccine no
we don't know the back side but it's
going to take a decade or do to learn
what's going on okay we'll learn what's
going on with that in the military they
would give us shots we had no idea
what's going to happen but once we learn
then we have to adjust if we don't
adjust and it's too late we're screwed
that's the concern so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]